making a movie the most immersive
experience possible is always really
interesting to me and I think really
powerful for audiences and so to be able
to show a movie like this in large
format is is really exciting anytime you
have a really wide shot of the city in
the capital that sort of thing is when
you get to feel the hugeness of it all
the locations lend themselves to imax
and seeing things on a greater scale
there's so much action start to finish
action like this the bigger the better
especially I think the lizard sequence
will be amazing to see in the big screen
the sense of being in this tunnel and
I'm actually is like monster things
coming after you it's going to be so
crazy
climax form that really adds to the
experience is everything that you hope
to accomplish on a big screen
emotionally and I matically powerful but
cinematically enormous I like the big
format also for for intimate scenes
their emotional scenes will be really
powerful on a big screen it has enormous
spectacle and enormous scope
repower to it it's incredible the imax
would be great in this film